il ya trente ans en afrique du sud un
chirurgien réussissait l'impensable
changer un coeur malade par un choeur
saint le professeur barnard accédait à
une célébrité planétaire même si c'est
des états unis qu'on attendait cet
exploit médical françoise vallée claude
sicard une extraordinaire nouvelle à
l'hôpital de grosse cure au cap pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de l'homme
une greffe de coeur a été réalisée sont
bénéficiaires
un épicier de 54 ans louis basse qu'en
ski parvenu au terme d'une maladie
cardiaque inguérissable dans sa poitrine
bat désormais le coeur de dany d'arval
une jeune fille de 20 ans tuée dans un
accident d'auto en quelques heures le
monde connaît le nom du chirurgien sud
africain qui a tenté cette opération de
la dernière chance
christiane bernard ce futur une émotion
fantastique
beaucoup de gens ont travaillé sur ce
sujet en particulier à l'hôpital
broussais et on attendait on fait que la
première soit fait tant aux états unis
par noël chez moi et cela 20 de
l'afrique du sud
le patient ne survivra que douze jours
mais la grande première du professeur
barnard incite les cardiologues du monde
entier à tenter l'opération
quelques mois plus tard en avril 68 le
professeur cabrol effectué la première
greffe du coeur en europe
là encore le malade décède quelques
jours plus tard en mai 68 toujours à
paris les professeurs du beausset
cachera récidive en opérant un père
dominique il survivra près de 18 mois
avec le coeur d'un autre
mais le doyen des greffés le symbole
d'espoir pour tous les cardiaques
c'est le marseille à emmanuel vite rires
c'est mieux apparemment l'opération
pourquoi parce qu'un jour au vif opéré
en 68 il a survécu 18 ans on le
surnommait l'indestructible aujourd'hui
grâce aux médicaments anti-rejets la
greffe cardiaque est une opération
sainte
mais malheureusement de plus en plus
rares elle souffre surtout actuellement
il faut le dire d'un manque de donneurs
d'organes qui est vraiment dramatique
alors les chercheurs s'oriente vers les
organes des animaux humanisés pour
éviter les rejets
c'est ce que l'on appelle les
xénogreffes les premières opérations
pourraient avoir lieu d'ici cinq ans